welcome to episode 42 of the michaela
peterson podcast
i spoke with dr dominic nishwitz also
known as dr dome on social media
he's a practitioner of a more holistic
type of dentistry
called biological dentistry that looks
at overall health
rather than treating your mouth like
it's a separate entity from the rest of
your body
he told me some honestly horrifying
information about mercury
and wisdom teeth and what happens when
you don't have them
which i don't i hope he's wrong because
the information in this podcast is
disturbing to someone who thought they
were more evolved with no wisdom teeth
me we talked about oral health and diet
and mercury and aesthetics
and much more this episode is brought to
you by true local that's t-r-u-local.ca
i showed you one of their steaks in the
last episode they sponsored
and i was going to show you lamb but i
don't have any lamb i ate at all
it's also super marbled and i would
highly recommend it
true local hooks you up with local
farmers they ship you sustainably raised
meat
if you use the code mp they'll know you
came from here plus you can add free
steak to your box
if you end up being horrified about your
teeth after this episode
feel free to check out true local
dossier
the more meat the better the teeth in my
opinion my gums and teeth were in
terrible shape before my diet my dad had
a similar experience
now i have less tooth sensitivity like
none and no bleeding gums
meat man check out trulocal.ca
try their lamb their rib eye their wild
salmon
their turkeys bomb too and use code mp
for free steak
enjoy this episode i think this is the
last episode i filmed
with bad lighting woo
and subscribe if you want to hear more
[Music]
dr dominique nishwitz welcome to my
podcast
thank you mikaya for having me it's a
pleasure i'm super excited to talk i
haven't really gone in
i do health episodes like half health
episodes half
random other episodes and i wanted to
talk to you specifically
because you do an interesting type of
dentistry it's not the normal type of
dentistry
so if we could start off could you start
by telling my audience
what kind of dentistry you do yeah i'm a
specialist in biological dentistry
and i would say biological dentistry 2.0
this is kind of the the overlap of
functional medicine
health optimization biohacking and
high-tech dentistry
with the goal being optimal health and
not just absence of disease
so it's a little bit contrary or not
next level to conventional dentistry
which is more about repairing things
true true okay so let's start by
so what does your practice look like
like do people come in and get their
teeth cleaned
like is it just normal like that or is
it more discussion based like
what is your practice like
yeah this grew over time so we have of
course we do
general dentistry everything you can
imagine from professional cleanings to
fillings
through everything but it's more like
because it's so
so specialized the patient's clientele
is probably also
a bit of a different spectrum so we have
we have had a
lot of chronic sick people over the last
10 years
but it's changing a little bit to also
um
like high performance athletes and more
like people that are interested in their
optimization or like health optimization
part and so what we do is basically
see all our patients remotely because
it's not possible to
yeah to see them all in person because
it's just too many inquiries for
for long years now and before corona we
had i would say at least 50
of all our patients came from everywhere
from abroad most of them actually from
the us
but basically from everywhere but
because of lockdown situation of course
most of them are now
again from germany where the um
office is located so we remotely plan
patients but they send in their current
panoramic x-ray which is just a
two-dimensional yeah x-ray where you can
see
basically all your teeth and i will have
a
little bit of a different look onto
these x-rays
in comparison to just a conventional
dentist
i'm looking at oral interference so i'm
really looking for
are there any metals installed in your
mouth are there root canals
are there possible cavitations what
about the bite in general
whereas normally when you're trained
from university you would just look
if there's any like real problem like
reparation wise for example
a cavity decay or
maybe a like a visible crown that
doesn't work anymore something like this
so
i'll plan the whole treatment according
to the
panoramic x-ray by the goal of getting
the patient
metal free free of all root canals
and also these cavitations which is not
even
like trained in university yet you can
go down this rabbit hole later
and yeah basically draw into this
panoramic x-ray what we're going to do
and i'm a specialist in ceramic implants
so i'm a surgeon basically
so i will remove all the root canals on
the drawings and
place ceramic implants wherever possible
and then
the patient the patient just get an
overall email which is like
step by step what we're going to do how
they should prepare for this surgery how
the lifestyle changes has to look like
and what the health optimization week
will look like when they
finally be here so they can start in
advance by preparing their bodies with
the right
nutrients and then if they come in it's
kind of like a whole week
where we combine everything we need to
yeah
to get you as healthy as possible by
starting with your mouth
first day initial examination of course
we use a cone beam scan that's a
three-dimensional x-ray to
really then diagnose what's really going
on like on the tip of the roots
in your jawbone and whatever and then
mostly on the next day we will give some
we do
do some blood works of course and we um
do nutritional ivs and then we remove
all just the dental part we just remove
all the metals and the special on the
safe
measurements not just the amalgam all
metals will be removed safely
and then on the third and fourth day
it's mostly my part where i'll do all
the surgeries
by then i mean removing very minimal
invasive
all the oral interference clean
everything
and we use of course everything that's
possible to help
recover your body or help with the
healing like ozone
apr membranes which is kind of like stem
cells
whatever you find hyperbaric oxygen
chamber red light therapy
all the stuff that current biohacking is
talking about is implemented
with the goal of first of all repairing
everything and taking out the source of
all the problems like
basically all chronic disease starts
there and then
install things that are neutral for your
body that
that are not even like electromagnetic
charged or
like can disrupt your immune system
basically it's all mostly ceramics
because this is the most natural stuff
available right now
and then the further days it's more
about recovery
and again nutrition nutrients they get
individual consults they can use
whatever treatment suits them so that
they will leave
the office like with a clean mouth which
helps
basically all bodily functions yeah
because all teeth are connected to your
whole system
and then it's regeneration phase so the
body will
need about three to six months to build
bone if you have to do bigger bone
grafts
it takes about six months and then if
they come back it's
um mostly restorative dentistry cosmetic
dentistry and building up but of course
always combined with questions about
nutrition
did they get their lifestyle checked
because all the things we do in your
mouth
in terms of surgery they only work if
the body is able the patient is able to
really
heal and regenerate so i have to have my
patients be anabolic
and not catabolic most chronic sick
patients are kind of like
so what is what does that mean exactly
catabolic basically means
that over years due to several factors
your body isn't able to really build
new tissue new bone it's more like it
destroys or breaks down
tissue to repair like it's more like a
survival mechanism it is normal for
chronic patients
and anabolic is the opposite doesn't
have doesn't necessarily mean you have
to
use any anabolic steroids like you may
be
familiar with this word from
bodybuilding anabolic just means your
body is able to build tissue and i want
to have the patient build
of course connective tissue gingiva gum
tissue
but also bone tissue and even teeth are
possible to regenerate for a little bit
at least
wow and if your body is able to and this
is why
a big part of all of this is our is the
nutrition
is the um i call it macronutrient timing
microderm tuning tunings like
food design concepts i developed and
micronutrients
bone healing protocol so basically
yeah we try to take everything that's
possible to
really get you to the next level of
health this is
yeah what motivates you besides the
high-tech craftsmanship which is
dentistry in itself like cosmetic
dentistry is just high-tech dentistry
or surgery but besides this if your
patient tells you oh i was depressed for
the last 20 years and now it's almost
gone i had shoulder
neck pain i had irritated bowel syndrome
i couldn't sleep i was um
feeling sick basically all day long and
now like
suddenly it all changes it sounds
but it's actually like it if you take
out all these all these
things that can interfere with your
whole immune system your whole
nervous system which starts here and
this happens overnight and this becomes
then a fulfilling job so you're not the
regular dentist anymore like
from hangover he's just a dentist he
doesn't even know about
about health it's more like you're
becoming a help like a real doctor
and who can really help and i think all
health coaches or doctors or
naturopathic doctors i'm dentist
entertaining doctor
um this is the motivation so it really
changes and
patients wait long times for their
appointments they prepare themselves
with nutrition so it's a
yeah full new concept in a whole yeah
other mindset that you
tap into and patients become your
friends
basically it's slow dentistry so you
have i have only one maximum two
patients a day
but huge cases like five six seven hour
surgeries straight up
um but very very minimal basis yeah
not old school big surgeon huge cuts
new school surgery no cuts if possible
wow okay that was a lot of information
uh that sounds
oh no no it was good that sounds
completely different to what people are
normally used to
when they go to a dentist like that
that's a completely different story
uh so you mentioned a lot of the focus
is removing
metals that people have in their mouth
so can you give me an idea
why are these like i know if you get
braces a lot of the times you get that
metal bar at the back of your teeth at
least in north america to keep your
teeth straight
and i think they probably use something
like surgical steel or something like
that
so are there issues with those kind of
metals
yes so when when i plan a treatment is
is always
hundred percent naturally even these
things called retainers
so we call it oral interference like the
sources of the problems can be the
metals
the root canals cavitation so the metals
by itself
can be problematic in terms of the
immune system your body can just be
allergic to it or becomes intolerant
to it because these metals basically
have no function in your body
it's just like something from the
outside is installed in your mouth or in
your body
24 7. then um
besides the allergy or the immune system
you can also be
these metals can also be toxic that
means you get a lot of
a bigger burden of toxicity in your
system so your liver gallbladder system
and also
of course your cytokines and immune
system again have to have a
higher load for example an amalgam
filling most people are familiar with
these black silver fillings
they contain 50 mercury and mercury is
still the most toxic non-radioactive
element known to men
but it's placed in in your body on your
teeth
this is only possible right now because
the fda regulates it
as a class class ii device so all
fillings
or crown works or basically all the
metals you use in your mouth
are class 2 devices like these glasses
so you don't
necessarily have to um do a
psychological approach for them and the
third component
besides immune system and toxic
toxicology is always nowadays we have
wi-fi 3g 4g ems
basically and if you have any sort of
metal in your body
it's not just your mouth could also be
your hip or your joints or whatever you
have replaced in terms of metal
can become an antenna and that is not
what i want to hear
i have a hip and an ankle replacement
there's no putting ceramic in there for
a while
just a human antenna yeah but it's good
if you know
that when you have these things in your
body installed at least you know and
then you have to
take different strategies to really
shield yourself a little bit
more because of course your body is
electric your cell has
like there's a like a millivolt
structure it's like minus
30 millivolts in interstellar and you
know
if you get in contact with let's say
your your cell phone radiation or wi-fi
um it changes and if you have any metal
in your mouse there's enough studies
showing that
normally if you do a phone call with
your cell phone the
electromagnetic waves go you go to your
cell phone and back to the tower
if you have any metal here it could even
be just disappearing
it goes through the metal here amplifies
in all directions
and up to for uh there's a study showing
400 to 700 fold and
of course over time this can really
disrupt your whole autonomic nervous
system which is kind of fine-tuned
and when you really look at the
millivolts and
of course all the metals in your mouse
can also corrode because if you place
different metals in your mouse let's say
you have a gold crown and an american
filling right next to it
or you have a titanium implant and a
gold screw in it on top of it
there will be voltages in it it's called
galvanic
element or just simply put a battery
and in your mouth you have the saliva
which is a liquid medium
and of course if you let's look at a
propeller from a boat underneath the sea
how does it look after 10 years it's
like totally rusted and corroded
same happens with all the metal
restorations in the sea which is the
saliva in your mouth so
it's really a lot of things that you
have to take in consideration just
by the metals in itself and this is only
one of the interference fields so
yikes in my opinion when it comes to
health optimization or
if you're chronically sick and you want
to come up to like start your health
journey
it is a really foundational work and
i've learned a lot from good mentors
like dr klinghart
and he's saying this for years that in
their opinion is like 70
of all chronic disease which is the
epidemic of this century
start in your mouth because your mouth
and your teeth are just an elongation of
your brain kind of like your eyes it's
32
little tiny organs connected to your
fifth brain
nerve cranial nerve the trigeminal nerve
and
yeah you cannot even imagine what i see
on a daily basis it's really insane so
this information is spread
to all the other doctors functional
medicine doctors so that's becoming
common
knowledge and everybody actually looks
differently in the mouth not just
repairing it really like there could be
the it could be the big splinter holding
you back for
reaching your next level health or even
health at all
yeah okay so for people uh i know they
don't generally do
mercury fillings at least around here
anymore but
there are a lot of people who are older
than me that have them in
uh is there a danger in just having a
regular dentist remove them
just regularly remove yes so first of
all don't panic if you listen to this
um i'm panicking now no no
yes do it with a strategy
don't just go to regular dentists and
just basically remove
the mercury filling because you learn in
university you just drill it out
and if you drill it out of course you
have more mercury vapor coming out and
i've seen
a lot of patients coming with
neurological problems or even
like way bigger problems after the
removal of the amalgam fillings because
when you have them placed in your mouth
they're kind of like
okay you bite on them you chew on them
you grind on them you drink acidic stuff
or like
foods you actually even brush your teeth
or go to
cleaning but you only release about two
to three micrograms of
mercury vapor per day it's still a lot
if you know that it's toxic but if you
drill it out it's like
a real mess if you just drill it out
just imagine you drill it out you now
have this black sand in your mouth and
your tissue you swallow it it will be
stuck into your in your whole system
forever
so then you just find a biological
dentist who is able to
remove amalgam safely and lately just
post it on my instagram
a safe amalgam checklist
it's just a little infographic but that
you could just use
show your dentist um are you able to do
or remove my
metals like this and if they do so it's
fine
and it's just up there's a few things
that are mandatory
you can see on the list it's like a
rubber dam at least
rubber dam is basically a if possible
it's latex free but it's
it looks like a latex like a cloth you
put over your tooth kind of like a
sterile
thing when you do a surgery and then
just the tooth looks out of it and you
see these tooths with the black filling
this um this tissue is more for for the
particles that break out
because studies show that mercury vapor
goes through seven layers of
um of gloves so it doesn't protect you
from the vapor but it protects you from
stuff that
falls out because what the biological
dentists do is
it i don't drill out or we don't drill
out the filling
kind of like drill around or break it
out
because then we don't release more more
vapor it's all about not releasing more
vapor than you already had in your
system
so the next thing that is mandatory is a
suction it's called the cleanup section
it's kind of like a yeah it it goes
around your tooth
it's a plastic thing and it has an under
suction in it
so this in itself on the section
is about i would say it's about 95 of
all the vapors will be sucked in
better it's a scandinavian thing but i
would say this
is in at least in german you can get it
everywhere like every dentist
and then we use a nasal probe where we
just fill in fresh air
and we have a huge air filter system
it's kind of like a big oven tube
um very loud but it sucks up 99.9
of the mercury vapor and cleans it it's
called an iq air so those are the things
that are mandatory and we also add in
so after the removal of the filling we
will do chlorella paste chlorella is an
algae that binds tightly or pretty good
to
mercury we just put it in for two to
five minutes into the cavitation into
the cavity
i did this in my residency just to
because i was
interested if it cleans these stains
that that are left from the melee and
yeah the tooth got lighter within one or
two minutes so i kept on doing this
makes sense
you could also use activated charcoal or
anything that binds for a few minutes
and then we we have an iv drip while
we're doing this or before we're doing
this
just to keep the immune response down
it's mostly vitamin c
b vitamins and it's bicarbonate protein
so it's kind of like um
alkaline and just helps your immune
system because we don't want to have a
an immune attack or something like this
and we try to remove the metals
in as little fittings as possible
because of the immune system and of
course
with all the measurements we try to not
get any of the particles or any of the
vapor
in your body not more than you already
have from
from wearing these things for the less
some people have it for 30 years 40
years
that's a problem this stuff really is a
good material in terms of reparation it
lasts forever in germany it's still
subsidized by the insurances
um i've never placed an american feeling
i learned it in university
but i knew for my dad that he was he's
also a dentist that he when we worked
together that he wasn't doing it
since the 80s didn't i wasn't interested
in this when i was in university but
afterwards when i couldn't do amalgam
because of aesthetic reasons and
my my boss in residency my surgery boss
he did it he still didn't i was like no
i can't do it it's not aesthetically
pleasing i learned new things and this
is when all these universe opened and i
learned all these things about the
toxicity because this is nothing you
learn in university
university you just learn good filling
material lasts forever is for free
kind of and it's only not allowed for
pregnant women and for kids and if you
have an allergy which makes no sense
but you have to remove it as highly
toxic waste
in your clinic and this can make me feel
wow
yeah okay highly toxic waste in your
mouth
yeah as soon as if if it's in your mouth
it's okay but as soon as
it's out it's highly toxic waste that's
great
yes and this is only possible because
it's
the wording is it's not really in your
mouth it's just
device like your glasses lying on top of
your tooth
outside of your body because your mouth
is basically not your body so biological
dentistry just basically means
that your mouth is part of your body and
if you
it basically it is the start to your
whole gut system it is
the entrance to your guts it's actually
your gut system
yeah it's the big tube that starts here
and ends over there
that goes through your body yeah and
nobody looks at your mouth from this
perspective and
there's so many things installed you
can't even see and the microbiome in
your mouth is like
way more diverse diversified than
further down
which makes perfect sense because it's
the entrance like everything starts
health starts in your mouth basically
the whole life
yeah so let me see where do i want to
start from that
you said you do a lot of nutrition work
with people before they come in to see
you or while they're there
so what kind of suggestions do you have
for people just to have a healthy mouth
like in terms of nutrition
and just to have a healthy mouth so
ideally your body
like in a natural world and if like
everything would be healthy
your body is immune against cavity so
you wouldn't
even need a dentist to repair anything
and this
all starts already actually in the womb
it starts by going through
the burst channel getting the
the microbiome from your mom basically
in your mouth and then breastfeeding
this is when basically teeth or tooth
and jaw development development starts
so you actually
have to start early but if you do so so
let's say perfectly when we can start as
a baby
so for future generations the perfect
world would be
like a regular birth breastfeeding for
at least one and a half years
the mom would be perfectly and
yeah trimmed with the right nutrition by
that i mean the macronutrients
like protein carbohydrates and fats
would be
in the ideal order so i go with two
grams of kilogram
protein ideally and
some healthy fats but basically as
natural as possible whatever you could
hunt
or fish um kind of like ancestral like
you
you probably do and pretty yeah and make
sure that
you have enough vitamin d3 sunlight like
the critical
micronutrients for teeth and bones are
always
vitamin d3 magnesium vitamin k2
omega-3 fatty acids and protein mostly
protein actually also
so that this this builds and then
the idea would be or the mindset is you
wouldn't need
braces you wouldn't need anything
because western price showed it
100 years ago ancestral diets or like
really nutritious
like um nutrition that is really
nutritious can you say that
yeah um yeah feeds your body and you
will
don't you're not having these narrow
faces because of the breastfeeding
your jaw develops pretty big yeah
the breastfeeding needs so much suction
force
that it grows your lower jaw and also at
the same time
you can only breathe through your nose
so at the same time
the baby gets or the little kid gets
trained to
breathe through you know through the
nose which um
leads to bigger nostrils wider faces
bigger shaped palates
and um of course good good
tooth structure and there's studies
shown pretty pretty newer ones actually
for the last two years
they're popping up in dentistry about
vitamin d3
and cavities just lack of vitamin d3 is
correlating with cavities new teeth or
soft mates
as well as a gluten intolerance or
celiac disease this is commonly
known if you look at it in functional
medicine for dentistry
it's probably not known in university
but um
makes sense like gluten intolerance or
celiac disease leads to a leaky gut or
inflammation
which further leads to lack of mineral
absorption or nutrient absorption and of
course
at the end you have soft teeth so you
basically can see everything
already in your mouth if you just look
at it from another
point of view and not just oh he has a
hole there's pain
we have to repair it's like just a
different
look at it and this is why of course
nowadays we have to be able to repair
things that have been done
or damaged through this dental career or
through the wrong diet standard american
diet leads to
of course insulin resistance and
metabolic disease
weak teeth crowded teeth mouth breathing
and narrow faces no space for wisdom
this is basically what boston bryce
showed 100 years ago
when he showed ancestral diets having
perfect aligned teeth
all wisdom teasing blades white faces no
scoliosis
very perfectly shaped and then the kids
which had already like contact with the
newer industrial foods like sugars
wheat or grains refined oils
and they look like a little tiny
monsters in his book nutritional
physical degeneration
basically here crowded teeth
narrow faces mouse breathing
no space for the wisdom teeth basically
what we see now with our teenagers so in
germany at least
it's almost never anybody who has a full
set of wisdom teeth
like me i had like i had to remove my
wisdom to tease when i was like
14 years old i had two sets of braces
didn't work at all i
feel like no bite so i had all these
i didn't have any cavities luckily but
um all the problems from the wisdom to
remove like cavitations i experiment
myself so if i have at one point like
patients with a full set of teeth like a
really
really wide jaw with all the wisdom
teeth
it's really like wow this is a rare
species here but this is actually
how it should be so we have to really
educate parents in my opinion as
dentists and i don't see myself as a
dentist more like a health optimization
doctor but in the future everybody
should be a health optimization coach
doctor
and just has the knowledge about just
also look into your mouth okay do you go
look into your detoxification
the full picture and then maybe we need
a specialist like me too
there's a guy who needs reparation he's
full of metal somebody has to do the
surgery
it's all down the line but i'd say i
have a few kids and
i try at least to give them a good
lifestyle and
improve on what i did maybe wrong when i
was a kid
so that they don't have to go see a
dentist yeah
oh cool if they want then there is a
dentist who tells them how to eat the
right foods and
get a better life out of it yeah yeah
that's way better
okay so what do people do if they're
already screwed up
so for instance uh i i have celiac
disease
my teeth were a disaster right i didn't
have cavities but
i had enamel erosion like crazy when i
was just a kid
um weirdly enough you have celiac
disease yeah
i haven't eaten gluten in in like
five or five years but uh yeah i do
so it it wreaked havoc on my teeth and i
ended up getting veneers
a while ago so what are your thoughts on
people who've already wrecked their
teeth
what what's the healthiest thing for
them to do
so it depends like like you said it's
all about the lifestyle it depends what
has been done already in terms of
dentistry so you personally you just had
weak enamel because of your celiac and
softer teeth so you
you had to repair them with veneers
basically but i hope so i don't know i
haven't seen your x-ray i hope
all the teeth are still alive so no root
canals
no so then it's fine it's just regular
reparation
you use what what was necessary what i
would
uh of course in your case do and you do
anyways
have your nutrition in check and know
deficiencies
i anyways recommend to all my patients
like the call for things like going on a
gluten-free diet is a standard
and no sugars we do dairy free because
we can get the good ones
and most of the time and the highly
refined oils and everything else will be
more individualized
this but is like you what i would do in
your case is
the next question would be i would i
need to see an x-ray but if i have the
x-ray or
i would just ask you what about have you
had wisdom teeth removed
no i don't have any wisdom teeth you
never had them or you don't know
no i i don't have them on x-rays they're
not there okay
so this is a good start actually i'm i'm
evolved
or less evolved this is actually this is
a sign of degeneration
don't take it it's called degeneration
yes
so in terms of like if you would be more
neanderthalitic or whatever you say in
english
and 10 000 years ago we all had a set of
two wisdom teeth and wider jaws because
we just eat
more meats and harder stuff and probably
one no
two cheese were just broken out and
there had had to be a next set
so what do you have in there before you
see a twos it's called a dental
butt like not budweiser the other one
like but
like a seed you know what i mean a
dental butt it's like a
it's like a little soft tissue that is
in the bone
and normally at one point it gets
activated and then a tooth grows out of
it
you don't have a tooth on your cone beam
then i know
from just experience that you probably
have
still the dental butt that didn't
develop which is
pathologic and this forms the biggest
cavitations i
mostly see because then in the bone you
have tissue
and over time the tissue just fairly
degenerates which is normal
and leaves kind of like a big cave in
there
and you have haven't you have a nice
microbiome in your mouth but
also in your diversified microbiome they
have fewer nastier bugs it's just normal
they're not bad
but they're in there like you have
pathogenic bacteria like
anaerobes sometimes even parasites
sometimes there's a bit of fungi
mold candida whatever and if you now
have a cave
in your bone this is becoming a
compartment
we call it layman's term you call it a
cavitation
a better germing is nico or the perfect
terms
the perfect term would be fdoj
fatty degenerative austin negrotic
jawbone
and this is a silent information
in your jawbone surrounding your
trigeminal nerve on a daily basis
and this area wisdom tooth area is
connected with your whole nervous system
and the meridian child with your small
intestine
and large a small intestine and heart
meridian
you heard of meridians yeah chinese
medicine
yeah yeah the whole central nervous
system gets switched over on this spot
so people that have the perfect x-ray
but they still come in with chronic
fatigue or ill-tail bowel syndrome or
any sort of autoimmune process
a lot of times have these cavitations
why
because we have these caves full of bugs
then so
dr lachner is a good friend of mine i
call him the yoda of cavitations because
he's doing
surgeries for 40 years and he's doing
all the research so he has
he is um i think he now has 12 to 13
peer reviewed
papers on this subject and yeah he
basically devoted his whole life with
the research of these cavitations
and what he found in there is actually
everything so
he found all the stuff i told you
pathogens mold
like in the us is a big mold problem
mold likes to grow in there
anaerobics and he also has found that
there's a special
chemo kind interrupt me if it's going
too deep no no no keep going i'm
horrified of cytokines
cytokines is like how your immune system
talks
but chemo is kind of similar but
has a different meaning to it so the
chemokine
in these cavitations is called
r-a-n-t-s rantis or you can also find it
on
as ccl5 in medical literature
and randy's is at the beginning it's
just there to tell your body oh there's
something rip to be repaired
it just tells or bring nutrients there
but if it's becoming chronic because
your body is not able to rebuild this
after let's say a wisdom juice removal
or because you have like still the
daniel butt in there
it becomes chronically activated and
it has been shown in thousands of
studies
that it can correspond or correlate with
problems
so if it for example if this randy's
actually um attaches to your
endocannabinoid receptor it's
you get prone to a neuralgia like
massive pain migraines and stuff
then it's then the diagnosis would be
the nico which is the neuralgia-inducing
cavitational osteonecrosis
across what you can find but if this
rantes for example
um leads to or
corresponds or correlates with
rheumatoid arthritis then you should
call it a rico
or if it's corresponding with the cancer
development there's a study showing
that it's um through the hyper
regulation of the immune system
it's correlating with the breast cancer
breast cancer it's done by
dr um johan leitner and focoven bear
and because of this ongoing stress
through this activation then you should
call it then you must call it a
kiko so the term nico really doesn't cut
it because it's so
multi-factorial and it's really hard to
diagnose
especially if you don't know and the
problem is all medical departments look
for this
ranitis chemokine so type in pubmed
or google scholar which is medical
research type in runts plus
let's say multiple sclerosis i'm quite
sure you find 300 papers in a second
but the dentist isn't looking there and
this is where the problem is it's an
oral problem
but it leads it works systemically
everybody looking
is looking for it but the only one who
really is able to remove it or
knows where it's coming from is the
dentist
where it's not being trained in
university because it's not universal
it's not university stuff not yet even
if it's there forever so
it's really it takes so much time and
and universities
yeah it's perfect it's the perfect
entrance for our job but
it's just lacking so we need more
education and just information
and it's there and you could open a
clinic and you'd be
you would be the woohoo doctor because
you can really help heal patients
overnight
because of taking out chronic
inflammation
in your jawbone surrounding your
trigeminal nerve
which starts in the brainstem and is one
of the 12 cranial nerves
and this trigeminal nerve actually takes
50
of the whole space so it's quite
important and imagine the nerve goes
from
here to here to here to here the anatomy
and it ends basically with your teeth
imagine
everything that's on your teeth or in
your teeth like the metals
the toxins from the root canal the
bacteria your nerve is
able to um transport
toxins and infections retrograde into
your brain stem
into ganglia and from there on in your
whole nervous system in every organ and
basically
um can ruin your whole nervous system
because of the chronic
ongoing cytokines and inflammation you
just have to get how your whole body
works
yeah and always the vagal nerve which
innervates the whole
um organs in your body the
parasympathetic nervous system
will be problematic if there are people
being in a chronic
fight and flight response 24 7 for
30 years just because of stuff like you
have in your mouth
and nobody even told you you didn't even
check because
oh man here i thought i was more evolved
with my lack of wisdom teeth that's what
i've been going off of
um yeah yeah you can wear it like this
can you see these cavitations on these
panoramic x-rays
um yes you can but you i'm not allowed
to diagnose on a panoramic x-ray up
but like i said at the beginning i will
always just do a preliminary diagnosis
on a panoramic x-ray so
feel free to send your panoramix may
look at it
in the office then when you're there for
the whole week we will do a new cone
beam scan and really diagnose them
because this is the gold standard
but also on the cone beam i'm only able
to diagnose a
difference in your bone structure what i
normally
see is just basically no bone structure
there so
um i get the bone here the jawbone is
sponges it looks like a sponge
and these areas then don't have this
tiny sponge microstructure
it's more like it's just black there i
can show this to all patients they see
it in a second
it's hard for dentists to get trained to
see this because they used to see other
things but if they know they find it too
and then the real diagnostics actually
happens
during surgery when i open it really
gently
i find really fatty mushy tissue you can
also check on my youtube there
further down there a few surgical videos
it's really nasty so i covered them a
little bit
because this is not for everybody's eyes
to show the insides but this is what i
see on a daily basis it looks like
yeah fatty fatty grayish
tumorous tissue that you suck up out of
there it's not bone
and that's horrifying sometimes actually
mostly for us patients you find huge
loads of really
macroscopic mold in there like really
more we tested this through
kinesiology through response testing so
it's really hard because if you have
mold growing inside your body
on top of your nervous system basically
in your brain it's just an elongation of
your brain until here
and here it's really your brain that
we're working on
and imagine what problems this could do
for your body because mold of course
wants
energy and um actually mold comes to
help you or wrecks you a little bit
and mold can also in their cell load up
load themselves up with loads of mercury
so
it's always a sign for a heavy metal
toxicity in itself
so these whole things reparation wise
metals in your mouth root canals
will lead to a really dysbiotic oral
flora and of course through real
dysbiosis in your gut system
so it's really important that you start
by the entrance of your gut
because health starts in your gut but
this starts in your mouth you know
yeah okay okay let's switch switch
directions i'm
horrified it's gonna this is this
podcast is gonna take me a while to
recover from
uh how do you feel about
fluoride we don't use any fluoride
fluoride is
um it is a toxin again
it's marketed or like what you learn in
university is that it like helps to get
stronger teeth and and also is it
it is a strong disinfectant this is uh
true
but why would that isn't affect a nice
microbiome
every day like on a daily basis or once
a week
and this makes no sense it actually
ruins everything
like because it doesn't kill just bad
bacteria there is actually no back
material
there is a diversified microbiome on
whenever you interfere with something
chemical that is
supposed to kill something it'll also
kill the commensal flora whatever
so we don't use it it also forms nasty
stuff in your stomach
and there's really no point of using it
and
um we go fluoride free this is for sure
we also don't use titanium dioxide
and yeah basically use a
toothpaste or whatever you use to clean
your teeth
something that you would eat because you
put it into your mouth
so in your engines in the entrance and
yeah we'll be uptight by your gum tissue
already
speaking of toothpaste uh what kind of
toothpaste should people
be using should they be making them
making it themselves like other things
to avoid
what do you use yes
i i would avoid off obviously the
fluoride and
most uh normal toothpaste are white
and the white color is e17 one is this
titanium dioxide
it's also a strong immune disruptor so
in a toxin
i would try to avoid this basically just
go into any
um let's say how you call it like
whole foods this is a natural
supermarket and then go into the natural
section and find something there
you could tell us there are a lot of um
diy
um how to build your own toothpaste
recipes online
yeah most of them actually start with
coconut oil space which i think it's
good
you could add in a few of the herbs
herbals like
i would also use coconut oil cooling for
example peppermint
or oregano and really make your own
things what i
what i wouldn't do is
like don't use any too strong abrasives
so
a lot of the toothpastes that are
marketed as whitening toothpaste
actually contain abrasives that will rub
off your enamel
so of course they maybe make you tease a
little bit more whitish
but that makes no sense so you could use
activated charcoal to do this even
even um there is a an ancient
um strategy to get cleaner teeth but
it's kind of nasty you would use
garlic and i wouldn't recommend it
because you probably then smell
extremely because if you brush your
teeth with garlic
but activated charcoal works a bit and
yeah but basically if you have if your
nutrition is in check
like you would eat an ancestrally um
i know you eat basically carnivorous
right yeah
pure carnivore just me you probably
wouldn't you probably don't even need to
clean your tears in my opinion why why
would you do
you probably have like perfect clean
teeth the whole day right
maybe you have something stuck into your
crown work
from time to time maybe yeah yeah that's
about it it's funny as soon as i
switched over uh
my plaque went away it just kind of fell
off
um so it's definitely improved my teeth
i know a lot of people who do the
carnivore diet
who still include dairy a lot of those
people still have
serious plaque problems uh yes
dairy i find dairy puts i i call the
plaque
it feels like fur on your teeth you know
what i mean so if you eat dairy you have
this little fur or if you drink a coca
i don't i don't know if i drank a coke
the last 20 years but
i remember as a kid that i always want
to drink a coke
i had this fur on my teeth and always
when i drank milk i had it i'm very
milk intolerant yeah yeah i had chronic
tonsillitis as a kid and lots of
antibiotics
found out when i was 16 and i was just
milk intolerant and this was just an
immune problem
and so i avoided it ever since then but
i always had this feeling of this milk
taste
and this is kind of like the plaque or
the plaque also if you eat carbohydrates
a lot of carbohydrates which you
probably don't in a carnivore diet
because it's uh
carbohydrates is the energy source from
the plants you probably don't even need
cleaning
i'm quite sure maybe you need it for
like just that you smell good you would
use something like it but
probably a coconut oil pulling will do
the trick and
i don't know about the teeth how good
they connect to each other because we
had crown work done
so i am not a fan of flossing because
this is something you wouldn't do in
nature okay
i wanted to get into this yeah because
it's just pretty simple let's see your
gum
your gum is tissue like your skin or
like your
inside and mucosa it's outside body
so most people if they're not really
gentle with their and flossing
they just rip it through and then they
bleed all the time that's also what
patients tell you
oh i'm always bleeding because they
don't know how to use it
what they do they whenever they use
floss three times a day
it's bleeding and this means you have
micro tear
or micro ruptures or like cuts in your
outside tissue
basically an open wound into in your
mouth
i call it leaky gum other people call it
further down leaky gut but this is
actually leaky gum so
already an opening for pathogens
for undigested foods into your whole
system because
bone underneath the gum or peridotium
is already inside body so you would
avoid this
why because this the gingiva forms kind
of like a really tight
structure around your tooth
around the tooth neck really protects
your body
and this should be really clean and and
lightish not red and yep
not red and bleeding if your gingiva is
red and bleeds
it is already open you have leaky gum
which is leaky gut kind of and yeah
this is something to consider you so
your ginger is really important so i
wouldn't use flossing of course you have
to use floss if you have done
if you had done reparation work like
crown work
or like a few fillings and it doesn't
fit perfectly anymore
and maybe you had some recessions and
now food is stuck in there of course you
have to get the food out of it
but besides this i wouldn't use it so i
personally don't floss only if
something gets stuck luckily i didn't
have any crown work or any fillings so
it's pretty rare yeah and yeah i'm only
cleaning once a day but i'm doing
coconut oil pulling pretty religiously
daily in the morning for my microbiome
and
for a good feeling for my saliva for my
whole pellicle on my teeth
to strengthen my teeth you know what
coconut oil no can you can you explain
that a little bit like how yeah what it
is how long you do it for
yes coconut oil pulling is a it's
probably an ancient tradition it's come
it i know it's also an ayurvedic
treatment i don't know if it stems from
ayurveda but
basically what you do you use an oil i
use coconut oil because it tastes good
and an extra virgin coconut oil because
of the laureate acid in it
is known to be antiviral antibacterial
so it's a good thing to use and it it
doesn't really kill too much it's just
like
maybe balances things out and also of
course it's
it stores fat soluble toxins so you use
this as a base i just take a teaspoon of
extra virgin coconut oil in my mouth
pretty simple then i have a few
essential oils
i just put in a drop of peppermint oil i
put in
two drops of oregano maybe at some point
i have an oral
probiotic i put a little bit of
probiotic in maybe a little bit of
propolis
you can go fancy there and then what i
do i gently swish it around
in my mouth for at least five minutes
up to 15 minutes and then i
don't drink it afterwards i spit it out
because it's then full of stuff that
should come up
and this will nourish your teeth it will
nourish your whole microbiome it will
nourish your saliva
so it's really a good strategy and also
because it's strengthening your immune
system which
is in your mouth so your saliva is full
of immune globulins it's full of
peptides
you know that if for your saliva
everybody knows when you
like hurt yourself you initially put
your finger in your mouth
because the histidine in there is like
peptides
activate or like kind of like glue it
together you also do it before your kids
it's just normal natural natural
strategy
so saliva is really like a super thing
it also is there to pre-digest your food
so digestion starts in your mouth
you know if you like cook that you start
and
producing more saliva yeah if it's
pretty
nice food this is how you prepare your
digestion this is really that you have
you should really take your time
while preparing your foods smelling your
foods but then also
chewing your foods i know when i was a
kid my grandma told me yeah you should
chew like 30 times
for vitamins like whoa i just wolf it
down but
over over times i really am learned how
to chew my foods and
it's it's really good and also cooked
start cooking and
not just eating for pure nutrients which
i probably did
years and years because nutrition is
what started all this like 20 years ago
and yeah i tried all mindsets this is
how i developed the food design concept
which is basically just my 20 years and
everything that worked from all the
different mindsets and like i said
before it's based on macronutrients
why because i see too many patients with
too many mindsets in terms of
the one is a vegan the other one is a
carnivore third one does
intermittent fasting low carb high carb
you know
so i just basically tell them okay
whatever you can be whatever you want
but make sure you get your nutrients
and it's more difficult as a vegan it's
really difficult and it's
probably not the best strategy from a
medical point of view
i know carnegie works very very well i
read the book i tried it myself
for years ketogenic whatever i like this
stuff i'm a blood type o hunter so
i cannot live without meat but of course
it's all about quality and about
um i would say um
awareness that you just have to live
within this society
with like the animal has to have a have
a
nice life so mass production of animals
mass production of
um plants both bad so it's regenerative
culture and all these things like
i have our own stock concept in my town
it's called the superfoods health food
barn store
it's like my little lego city concepts
that are all put in together so
that my environment is kind of like as
natural as possible
and for my patients also yeah it's my
passion i'm doing this for long years
now
yeah okay
uh you you talked a little bit about uh
activated charcoal
so how do you recommend people use that
you can use that for whitening right
or does it work there are toothpastes
that are based on activated charcoal
you have to know that your teeth will be
black or grayish while you're
rubbing them and i think actually
in my interview with ben greenfield he
mentioned this that he was using it i
never tried it
but i know it works for clean if
[Music]
it works for whitening and the abrasive
scale or how you call
the abrasive yeah how abrasive it is
yes it's okay for teeth so you could use
it there was a little bit of a
discussion back and forth but i think
it's debunked you can
i personally don't um i think your teeth
if your nutrition works if you get the
nutrients your teeth are rebuilding
themselves from the inside so from the
pot
but also through the outside through the
saliva
so if you have all the nutrients you
need and the minerals
is what makes your tooth white or not as
white yeah
it's a crystal structure so in my
opinion
you just put in the minerals and then
you get hot teeth
teeth are supposed to be hard as granite
granite like
like stone and sensitive so that they
can
touch like a hair so it's really a crazy
organ harder stone but very sensitive
um and you get it from there and then
you could i'm not
i'm not for example i'm not against
professional
tooth whitening this is something you
can do in an office we also do cosmetic
dentistry
if you feel like needing a little bit of
cleaner or whiter teeth
let's do it from a professional it's
basically also just
it is a chemical you use and it
basically
um you cannot go overboard so the teeth
won't get
wider as the natural will be but over
time if you like drank a lot of coffee
if you drink a lot of red wine and like
just like
stain your teeth a bit you can get them
more natural
through these structures through these
things make sure though
when you do stuff like this that you
optimize before that your body doesn't
have
is not depleted by minerals because it
will further deplete you a little bit
while doing it
so we always have our patients on the
bone healing protocol which evolves
around 20 000 ius of vitamin d3
daily combined with all cofactors
there's no sensitivities
but i tried it like 10 years ago once or
15 years ago when i
i think longer i was still in university
i was kind of like my dad's
guinea pig so we have a new machine you
want to try it
sure so i had massive pain so i never
bleached again
but i know my wife and a lot of people
later on with the right nutrition they
have no problems at all oh
interesting i haven't tried again so
maybe i will do it
test it again yeah to see once your
vitamin d is higher maybe it'll make a
difference that would be interesting i
know from patient that it
makes a real difference if you if you're
optimized before
and i can tell you i wasn't optimized in
university when i
yeah it's more about partying you know
and
and so i had pain and my wife for
example
she never has any pain she's not she
i think if you once have your teeth
bleached so this is how we do it we
bleach it and the office ones
have your nutrition and your lifestyle
then in check they stay pretty clean
and you get if you want to you can have
a splint for at home use
like a home bleaching kit
and whenever you your teeth get a little
bit grayish again
like let's say every six to six months
to a year you just
put in this thing for one or two nights
and they're good to go again
so you have to get like you have to use
a strategy to get where you want to be
but if you're there the maintenance is
pretty easy
i had massive tooth sensitivity that
just made going to the dentist
impossible
i don't anymore at all since i switched
my diet it completely ended it used to
be so bad that if i inhaled
air through my teeth like it would hurt
and and now it's it's completely fine so
changing my nutrition completely changed
my tooth sensitivity thank goodness
because it was very unpleasant
yes and this this goes along with what
western price said he
he kind of had a first boning protocol
so what he did was
he so
he it's pretty clear that your body is
able to build
new dentin so dentin is below the enamel
it's the tiny structure below
and it's called tel tera in english i
don't know
telstra dentin like third dentin if you
rebuild it
to rebuild it you need vitamin d3 you
need um
you need vitamin k2 magnesium and all
these things and what western price back
then did
he gave his patients um cod liver which
contains vitamin d3
and he gave them butter like a mixture
out of it
he said in butter from grass-fed cows
there must be something in it
that that he called activator x and
chris masterjohn found out in 2009 i
think for price pottinger which is
by surprise foundation that this
activator x
is is vitamin k2 which you now know and
this is also
part of the bone healing in the protocol
they are basically all the
micronutrients are fine-tuned
around the the vitamin d3 being maybe
the
mvp of this team and
we have enough magnesium in there we
have enough k2 in there we have all the
b vitamins and activated form in there
there's omega-3s
vitamin a there's even boron and zinc
and all the cofactors you need
to really activate vitamin d3 receptors
boron for example is
shown to elongate your vitamin d3
half-life to double so normally the
activated vitamin d3 is only 15 hours
and then it's 30 hours so it's good
and boron is amazing you can have look
look up the study nothing boring about
boron
it's a real review study medical
literature
and if you just see what it does like it
helps with all the snips it helps with
cmt with methylation with heavy metal
detoxification
it elongates your vitamin d3 it up
regulates testosterone
so that helps with recovery so if you
just read this you want to have this you
want to have this medication
it's amazing and it's just a simple
trace mineral and it's in my bone
healing protocol
um yeah but this is just a fine tuning
of the nutrition so it's always food
first
from macro to micro but you can do so
many things by just doing this i would
say lifestyle is 90
because and this is also medical
research nine out of ten chronic
diseases are lifestyle-based like you
said you had celiac disease
you had autoimmune problems because of
leaky gut because of all these
inflammations because basically your
whole immune system was in a
let's say it was in aggressive mode yeah
aggression mode and yeah you end up
having
is it a metal hip now metal hip and
metal ankle
can i ask this how old are you 28 but i
had it done when i was 17.
yeah i would say you were like 25 thank
you
yeah you
yeah well thank you very much for coming
on
um where can where can people find you
online
you can find us on our website it's
dnaesthetics.te
you can find me on youtube just by
typing in dr dominic issues
um and on instagram it's kind of like my
personal health
magazine where i share dental hacks but
also lifestyle hacks and all these
optimizations things
that this is at dr domi number one
because dr dom was already taking i
reckon
and yeah and actually on instagram
there's a tab bio in my bio
where this will lead to all resources
i've written a book it's called it's all
in your mouth
which is written for the layman and so
it's not a medical textbook it's really
to showcase all like this whole um
health starts in your mouth thing
and yeah i think that's basically it
like
this is really fun great thank you very
much for coming on
i'm slightly horrified i told you it's
going to take a while to recover from
this but that was
really interesting so thanks again
thank you very much for having me it's
my pleasure was a lot of fun
talking to you
you